побачили нове розпорядження голови
Верховної Ради України про порядок
закордонних відряджень ми розуміємо що
це є розпорядження яке спрямоване прямо
безпосередньо проти однієї політичної
сили а саме фракції європейської
солідарності на нашу думку це
розпорядження порушує засадничі речі
представництва народних депутатів
інтересів своїх виборців А як всередині
країни так і на міжнародній арені ми
вважаємо що це розпорядження воно є
перевищенням службових повноважень паном
спікером і є на жаль тим розпорядженням
яке сьогодні буде перешкоджати захисту
національних інтересів України Ми
сподіваємося що нам вдасться добитися
спільно з іншими колегами будемо
закликати інших колег відміни цього
розпорядження і ми готуємо цілий
комплекс заходів для того щоби не дати е
цим авторитарним тенденціям всередині
українського парламенту розвиватися далі